Everyone is talking about AI.
But most of what you are seeing… is
noise.
Hype threads. Tool lists. Videos that
promise to change your life, and leave
you no better off than when you started.
This channel is different.
And in the next few minutes, I want to
tell you exactly what we are building
here—and why it might be the most useful
thing you watch this year.
Here is what I kept seeing.
Courses that teach you AI theory, without
ever showing you how to actually use it
at work.
Tool tutorials that walk you through
features, without ever showing you how to
build a real workflow.
Content built for Silicon Valley that
completely ignores the reality of
professionals working in Lagos, Nairobi,
Accra, and everywhere in between.
I wanted something different.
Something that treated AI as a practical
skill. Not a buzzword. Not a trend.
Something built for the global workforce,
with African professionals at the centre.
[confident, slightly energised—this is
the reveal].
So, I built the AI Playbook.
….
The AI Playbook is a practical AI
education series, running every week,
built around one simple idea.
You learn by building. Not by watching.
Every session, we take one real AI
concept. One real tool. One real
workflow.
And we break it down, step by step, until
you can use it yourself.
Today. Not someday.
We cover things like:
How to build AI workflows that actually
save you time at work.
How to use large language models, without
getting burned by hallucinations.
How to automate tasks you are doing
manually, right now.
How to think about AI as a practitioner,
not just a user.
[warm, grounded].
And we do all of this with real examples,
real tools, and real context—built for
professionals who do not have the luxury
of six months and a PhD to figure this
out.
If you are a developer trying to
understand how to build real applications
with AI, this is for you.
If you are a business professional who
keeps hearing "we need to integrate AI"
and has no idea where to start, this is
for you.
If you are an entrepreneur, a manager, a
student, or anyone who wants to use AI at
a level that most people have not yet
reached.
[slight pause for emphasis].
This. Is for you.
[reassuring, unhurried].
You do not need to be a machine learning
engineer.
You do not need to already know Python.
You just need to be willing to show
up—and build something.
My name is Noah Olatoye.
I am the founder of InstinctHub—a
platform that has trained over five
thousand learners across Africa and
beyond, in tech and design skills.
I am also a digital transformation
consultant. I work with organisations to
help them apply technology in ways that
actually move the business forward.
I am not here to sell you AI hype.
I have seen the hype.
I have also seen what happens when people
and organisations learn to use AI with
real discipline and real structure.
[measured emphasis].
The difference is significant.
And that is what the AI Playbook is here
to close.
Every week on this channel, you will get
a full AI Playbook session, a structured,
step-by-step walkthrough of one AI
concept, tool, or workflow.
Short-form breakdowns, quick, focused
lessons you can apply in under ten
minutes.
Real case studies, showing how AI is
being used in professional contexts that
matter to you.
And everything we publish here is backed
by a full community, a place where you
can ask questions, share what you are
building, and learn alongside
practitioners who are doing the same work
If this sounds like what you have been
looking for, here is what to do next.
Subscribe to this channel. Every week,
there is a new session. Missing it means
missing the work.
….
Then, join the AI Playbook community. The
link is in the description below.
That is where the real conversations
happen. Where you can bring your
questions, share your projects, and
connect with practitioners who are
building with AI right now.
The community is free to join.
And it is where everything begins.
[pause, let it settle].
We are building something serious here.
And I want you to be part of it!
[excited] Click the link. [happy] Join
the community. [energetic] Let us get to
work.
[calm, deliberate, brand sign-off].
The AI Playbook.
Practical AI education for the global
workforce.